When you restore old movies
normally...
the people who made
those movies are no longer there.
So you can’t really ask them,
"What was your original
intention here?"
In our case, I was lucky,
I knew the original intention.
And in the case of let’s say
"Alice in the Cities" I knew...
that Robby and I
had dreamt to shoot it in 35mm.
That year was the very first year...
the self-blimped 35mm camera
came out, the Arriflex BL.
But they only had prototypes.
We couldn’t get
our hands on one.
Because we were shooting
with direct sound,
we had to shoot on 16mm.
And we hated it.
Because our dream was
to shoot it in large screen, 1.66,
which at the time was a regular
format in Europe. Not anymore.
But at the time we dreamt
of shooting in large screens.
So on that crummy 16mm camera
we had in the window
we had marks where 1.66 would be.
And so we framed for that.
Of course we had to shoot
full frame also for television.
And then as things go
you make prints,
nobody cares the director
initially wanted
to have it in 1.66.
It was always screened
in 16, in 3x4 full frame.
Now, we suffered,
because I always
saw our original
intention in there.
So when we restored it now
went back
to the original negative,
scanned it,
meticulously restored it,
"Alice in the Cities" was dead.
The negative was dead,
they had made 160 prints
of a 16mm negative,
it was dead.
There was nothing left,
and it was so scratched and torn,
and had so many wounds,
it was unbelievable, but still...
we were able to restore it,
took the longest time
of all the films.
And in the end, I said, “Well...
if we’ve done all of this already
and it looks so good again,
then I’d like
to have it in that format
that I was dreaming
of already at that time.”
So we radically went for 1.66,
the frame
we had initially in mind.
And I know that maybe
some conservative restorators will...
whine and say,
“We only know this film in 3x4.”
And I would say, “Unfortunately.
But now you see it
as I meant it.”
And that’s the advantage
if you do it yourself.